I think I've only had beets like twice
two times in my life this is the second
time yeah I just heard about this
restaurant called gem that's owned by a
19 year old chef and apparently he
charges $155 per person for a 14 course
tasting menu he's invited us to check
out how he prepares his favorite dish
let's see what it's all about we do two
seatings a night okay sort of everyone
comes to the same time so almost like
kind of like a dinner party in a way how
did you decide on this concept well as I
started sort of cooking by doing these
dinners in my house or my in my parents
house I I started sort of trying out and
little things when I was like 10 and
then I started getting really into it
when I was when I was 12 and that's when
I started doing these sort of dinner
parties what were you serving as at
12:00 I mean it was like a full like 10
course tasting menu
do your parents also cook I kind of got
into it because I didn't really like my
parents cook okay that's fair yeah
this is your favorite dish here yeah in
a way it's hard to tell what it is it
doesn't look like much right now so this
is this is a beet it's been smoked
braised and then dried it is we wanted
it to have the sort of same texture of
the steak we just sort of move it around
in the pan for a second it just creates
this sort of like really kind of hard
crust okay so it's softer and then it'll
it'll kind of dry up and put in the oven
but so what happens is the sugars go to
the outside it all caramelize is a lot
quicker this is just a little sauce that
we make so it's all of the scraps that
come out of making the beep we smoke it
and let me cook it down to make a
traditional steak sauce but with beats
both beats yeah we take just some some
of the greens from the beet kind of like
creamed spinach basically everything
you're doing is beet related it's all
yes it's all coming from it it's like an
ode to beat the funny thing about this
dish is like it came out of this
fascination with not loving beets Oh
wanting to make something that I thought
was really delicious and interesting
uh-huh and then it comes out just like
this and you wouldn't even know that it
took yeah many many days to work on so I
yeah is there a specific way I should
eat it no right just like treated at
stake this is really interesting like I
can't even taste the meat with the sauce
well what's weird is the Sun like it's
all beets so that's the funny thing we
have so many we were like I don't like
beets in this state I can't face it but
it's like no this is literally the most
beauty tasting things actually get
because it's there's nothing else in
there right yeah my mind is like blown
so this is one out of 14 courses is this
kind of like what you do with the whole
tasting menus is your second-to-last
savory course you're not only getting
little tiny tasting things you're making
a few kind of bigger more substantial
courses as well how much is like a
hundred
it's a hundred fifty five one hundred
fifty-five per person that's like not a
small sum of money it's not a place that
people come every single night and I
mean that that's the idea of it we
really wanted to get the best of
everything and unfortunately we're in
New York City everything's very
expensive that sort of also why we have
the living room in the daytime was we
wanted people to still be able to
experience the space and be in here
without if they couldn't afford the
price tag at night this this has been
the goal for so long and so it sort of
reset the clock of it's like okay now I
have what I've been trying to get for
nine years now this sort of dictates
everything that comes next
[Music]